hey theo hey travis hey baby hey man
this is josh
southern indiana travis i've seen you in
concert a couple times
always remember the tribute to waylon
jennings
tell me how he influenced your life and
your singing thanks man
gang gang gang brother and i'll and i'll
and i'll tack on to that question thank
you for the question man
and i love you brother thank you for
submitting that and um
yeah you kind of got accepted by like
the
you got that that dirty thumbs up from
the bad boys in a weird way you know
which was
what was that kind of like you know and
i guess what role did kind of whalen
play in that and um
yeah waylon told me that first time i
met him
he um i was getting ready to leave we
came into the dress and we were playing
a show together at the omni in atlanta
and uh and you're younger than him by
how much i know that but
a lot um 20-something years 30-something
years
so do you or is it like when you're
spending time with him is it i mean it's
almost like
it's like a seventh grader being around
a ninth grader i'm assuming he was a
hero
i mean i loved everything about him
before i ever met him i loved his
singing voice i loved his songwriting i
loved his guitar picking i loved
everything about him
but one of the things i loved about him
was he was not afraid to do things
his own way and um he sat me down
in his dressing room that first that
first time we ever met and he said
listen i've been
listen hoss i've been hearing all the
stuff that they've been saying about you
in nashville and on these radio stations
he said let me just remind you that
everything that they are saying about
you now
is exactly what they said about me
and about willie nelson and johnny cash
and hank williams jr and david allen co
all he just goes down the list and he
said let me ask you a question
he said um are you still
selling records and i said yeah i said
man i've been lucky everything i've done
so far
sold platinum or better a million copies
are better and he's
he said well are you still drawing
people into your shows i said yeah man
we're playing
huge arenas and they're sold out he said
listen those are the people you should
care about their opinion
because all these people in nashville
they're saying all this stuff about you
they get their
their music for free he said these
people that come out there he said those
are the people that work hard
40 50 60 hours a week to put
food on the table for their families
yeah and he said
and they're willing to spend a certain
amount of that
hard-earned money to buy your music
every time you put out new music and
occasionally they'll splurge for a
concert ticket
to come see you when you play in their
hometown
he said those are the only people that
matter and as long as you're pleasing
them
which you obviously are to hell with all
the rest of these people yeah
and man that was like an epiphany for me
and it also it took a tremendous amount
of weight off of my shoulders because i
realized at that particular point
whalen and all the rest of those guys
that were labeled as outlaws
they got that label by simply doing the
same thing that i was doing which is
just
wanting to do my music my own way
and do show my influences all my
influences
which were very
widespread i love i grew up country was
always my
center george jones merle haggard that
was my center
but i also grew up loving the allman
brothers leonard skinner marshall tucker
band
yeah charlie daniels and then of course
the eagles and boston
and and fleetwood mac and you know all
this other stuff
and then blues i was always a blues fan
still am
your voice has a lot of it man when i
listen to some of your tunes i'm like
man this reminds me
there are moments where it goes into a
god like a
light gospel you know what i'm saying or
a light uh
it takes me through like the different
neighborhoods that were
you know adjacent to the neighborhoods i
grew up in it takes me through
there's just uh yeah i can really i can
feel some of that man
well mississippi man i mean that's so
much great blues stuff came out of there
you know and uh that's one of the
reasons why
that was that was always a staple if you
take if you take blue grass and if you
take
um blues
and straight ahead country and southern
rock
and mix all those together and then
sprinkle a little bit of southern gospel
over the top of it
gospel baby that's me looking for the
lord man that's like jerry clower he
ended up being a pastor at the end of
his time i think yeah i think so
he was a preacher at the end of his time
here's a picture right here we go back
to that sean here's a picture of you
and uh and mr jennings right here is it
kind of interesting to see this photo
oh yeah that was the first time we met
really that was right before we had that
conversation
that i just told you about and was he
like uh did he carry himself like an
outlaw car oh
he had that jesse james vibe a little
his give a was totally broken
he didn't care dude that's awesome man
yeah man
to have that moment right there yeah
that was the first night
and did he have any traditions that you
noticed kind of backstage or what was
kind of did he have any
i as far as traditions i don't you know
uh we were allowed to spend time with
him backstage before we kind of like to
be by himself or did he no he was he was
always really good about
you know anytime i was around he and i
we
whalen was one of the kind of people if
he liked you he let you know it
and uh one of his
favorite sayings that uh that i remember
was because a lot of people would they
would talk about
man when you do this many shows do you
warm up or do you
how do you prepare for a show and
whalen's favorite answer to that
question was
i get up off whatever i'm sitting on and
go out and play music for people that's
what i do
and that answer alone just gives you an
idea of what it is
his his he was just cool man a cool guy
and a guy that was just you know
wanting to do his kind of music his own
way and that's
what he was going to do and he didn't
give a what anybody thought about
that i love that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one